[Applause]
[Music]
congress this weekend finally passed the
one trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill and while this bill
will provide funding for more
traditional hard infrastructure projects
a second soft infrastructure bill
focused on social welfare and climate
change is still languishing in congress
what's the big deal what this country
really needs are new roads and bridges
sorry that's one of my writers and ian i
disagree hard infrastructure is great
but personally i think we need something
a little
softer
softer
how do you mean
can i get a mic
[Music]
we need a little medicare medicaid
some parental leave that is fully paid
can you do good
all right
i'm talking free child care and pre-k
forget it each and every parent gets a
child tax credit babe
okay i think i see where you're coming
from
taxing billionaires lowering drug crisis
and while we're at it might solve the
climate crisis
[Music]
okay okay soft infrastructure does sound
pretty nice but
for my money i still think we need
something a little
harder
harder how do you mean can i get a mic
[Music]
i want them to pave my road i want my
subway full i want them to fix my bridge
and fill my whole pothole
oh
okay so like significantly harder i want
a new highway system so the traffic
doesn't funnel and i want them to start
digging on every one of my tunnels
i think we get the gist
internet access pay it with my taxes
somebody fix my pipes and nasty
you do okay
was it too hard
yeah and that was a little too hard i'm
sorry
i guess the lesson is that we need both
hard and soft infrastructure
well the real lesson is not to just be
handing us microphones
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you